here to help make sense of this all is
cryptocurrency expert and author of
undressing Bitcoin Leia Halpern Leia
thanks so much for your time we always
appreciate it so my first question here
is one of the benefits of crypto is you
know better than anyone is that it's
hard to track it's not in the
government's business where you spend
your money as long as you're not
breaking the law but one of the problems
Leia is it's hard to track and when
there's fraud involved there's almost no
way to get this money back is there
that's correct usually
um it should be actually easy to track
because you do have a transparent
blockchain unfortunately in this
situation and according to the
bankruptcy filings all customer funds
actually just went into one pot one
simple pot which is absolutely absurd
and that money then just went to
wherever they felt whether it's buying
their parents houses down in the Bahamas
whether it's being as you mentioned the
second largest donor to Biden's
presidential campaign whether it's
putting on fun parties down in the
Bahamas for the likes of Tony Blair and
Bill Clinton it's truly going to be
impossible to find out where this money
went and unfortunately I don't think
people are going to get um their money
back but my biggest concern here is
regulation I think Regulators are going
to use this as an excuse to usher in
more regulation we've already seen
Senator Warren introduce her Bitcoin kyc
self-custody bill which is illogical and
impractical
um and also I don't really understand
what more regulation is even going to do
because fraud is already illegal so I'm
very and it's not very clear what's
going to happen here
yeah I was going to ask you that as a
follow-up as a perfect leader Leia this
is just a case of pretty simple
embezzlement I mean even the new CEO up
on Capitol Hill I think his name was
John Ray said listen this really isn't
that complicated people deposited their
money with this company and this guy
allegedly just took it and spent it I
mean we're not wrong it's just simple
invisible he could have done it with
checks or gold or coins or dollar bills
exactly and that's actually the really
important Point here because I don't
want people to think this has anything
to do with crypto because really it
doesn't it's just a classic classic case
of human corruption human greed and
fraud and so it's no surprise to me that
he's looking at um two life sentences
because the most notorious fraudster uh
Bernie Madoff he got two life sentences
plus 40 years and so for me personally
I'm gonna be keeping my eye on
regulation what we're seeing as well
this message this mess is massively due
to the lack of clarity and the fact that
Americans aren't really expecting any
crypto for any regulation to be coming
anytime soon and so what this does is it
actually pushes these cryptocurrency
entities offshore makes them have to
operate in that gray area which of
course um hurts retail investors but one
last point I do want to make is that in
terms of Regulation well sambang with
freed and FTX were actually working very
closely with Regulators over the last uh
six months I believe and it's very
strange to me that they didn't know that
this company were fraudulent as a
solvent so again I'm not really sure
what regulation is going to do here